die klimakrise verschlafenen der
pandemie durchgewurschtelt und den
afghanistan-einsatz mit einem
historischen debakel beendet selten
stand eine koalition am ende ihrer
amtszeit so in der kritik wie die
aktuelle mit verantwortung dafür trägt
auch olaf scholz vizekanzler und
finanzminister
warum er als spd kanzlerkandidat lieber
über erfolge als über grobe fehler redet
das frage ich ihn hier in potsdam seiner
wahlheimat herzlich willkommen zum zdf
sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo willkommen beim zdf
sommerinterview hallo schöne montag
wollen hier in potsdam das ist in diesem
wahlkampf ein ganz besonderer und zwar
einzig artige ort denn nur hier können
sich die wählerinnen und wähler
tatsächlich direkt entscheiden zwischen
frau berbalk und ihnen sie treten im
selben wahlkreis als direktkandidaten an
sie kennen sich selber ja schon ganz gut
aus anderen wahlkämpfen sind sie ein
guter verlierer wenn frau berbalk hier
gewinnen sollte als direktkandidatin ich
glaube dass ich das votum der bürger von
bürger für diesen wahlkreis bekommen es
fühlt sich so an wenn ich hier rum gehe
mit vielen sprecher die frage nicht ganz
beantwortet wir sind hier in potsdam
auch nicht weit weg von dem ort an dem
ihre bundesregierung in nur neun tagen
einen großen zapfenstreich machen wollte
um das ende des afghanistan-einsatzes
feierlich zu begehen jetzt ist die
situation eine völlig andere sie müssen
sehr hektisch soldaten wieder hin
schicken um zu retten was zu retten ist
vor allem menschen leben wenn sie auf
diese fatale fehleinschätzung schauen
war das der größte fehler ihrer
bisherigen politischen karriere bin sehr
bedrückt dass die usa frankreich
großbritannien aber auch deutschland der
überzeugung waren dass das nicht so
schnell gehen wird dass es
möglicherweise auch der afghanischen
regierung gelingt die eigene sicherheit
zu gewährleisten
da sind viele soldaten gewesen der
afghanischen armee aber regierung und
afghanische armee haben das land nicht
verteidigten die bürgerinnen und bürger
das ist etwas was nicht so vorhergesehen
wurde und deshalb ist es notwendig dass
wir jetzt das richtige tun insbesondere
bin ich sehr sehr dankbar für den
einsatz den unsere soldaten soldaten
jetzt da an den flughafen leisten denn
der ist gefährlich das thema setzen wir
gleich noch fort aber das machen wir
gerne besitzen können sie mit
[Musik]
herr scholz wir stehen jetzt in an einem
punkt wo es einen umbruch geben wird von
der großen koalition zu etwas anderem
wir wissen noch nicht was dabei
rauskommt aber man kann auf jeden fall
schon mal sagen dass selten eine
bundesregierung so in der kritik
gestanden hat am ende ihrer amtszeit wie
ihre jetzt ich möchte gerne reden mit
ihnen über die mitverantwortung eines
vize kanzlers in einer solchen regierung
und würde gerne bleiben bei dem thema
das momentan emotional alle so sehr
bewegt das ist afghanistan die grünen
haben im juni im bundestag einen antrag
gestellt die visa verfahren für
ortskräfte afghanische ortskräfte zu
beschleunigen damals hat die spd dagegen
gestimmt warum hatte das für sie und
ihre partei damals keine priorität das
ist von der regierung entschieden worden
dass wir die ortskräfte herausholen das
ist exekutives handeln und deshalb ist
auch ein verfahren wie die ortskräfte
bestimmt werden können wie sie wiesen
bekommen kann festgelegt worden zwischen
den zuständigen ministerium und von
denen damals identifizierten knapp
2.400 kräften sind auch fast 2000 schon
in deutschland gewesen als wir dann
diesen furchtbaren zusammenbruch der
afghanischen regierung erlebt haben wo
sich die regierung davon gemacht hat ihr
land im stich gelassen hat und auch die
armee das land nicht verteidigt hat
deshalb müssen wir jetzt handeln und
dafür sorgen dass wir diejenigen noch
haus holen die wir sowieso schon
identifiziert hatten und all diejenigen
die jetzt wegen der neuen umstände auch
schutz suchen in deutschland
unterstützen sie beschreiben jetzt das
regelverfahren das ist ja genau die
frage warum hat die spd sich nicht dafür
eingesetzt von diesem regelverfahren
abzuweichen weil es viele hinweise
darauf gegeben hat dass sich die lage
rapide verschlechtert sie selbst haben
am 10 august noch gesagt abschiebungen
nach afghanistan sind in ordnung und
sollte man weiter beibehalten da hatte
sich die lage schon verschlechtert warum
hatte das für sie damals keine priorität
es hatte priorität ich habe die
priorität gerade berichtet wie man das
hinbekommt und deshalb ist es ja auch in
der diskussion gewesen vom
verteidigungsministerium und
außenministerium zu gucken ob man die
frage der visaerteilung auch vor ort
hier in deutschland regeln kann das ist
jetzt auch so entschieden und was die
frage abschiebung betrifft gibt es ja
zwei dinge die man im blick haben muss
erstmal es muss einen klaren grundsatz
geben der lautet wer hierzulande
schwere straftaten begeht kann nicht
darauf rechnen dass er hierbleibt und
selbstverständlich ist es so dass immer
wieder überprüft wird ob eine situation
eintritt in das noch durchgeführt werden
kann soweit man sagt doch nicht um das
kann man nicht natürlich führen sie
nicht glaube dass das was jetzt die neue
lage ist nämlich dass dort eine
situation entstanden ist in der
überhaupt niemand mehr rein kommt und
wir uns alle mühe geben viele
rauszukriegen natürlich eine veränderung
ist und deshalb wird das immer wieder
überprüft aber ich sage schon man muss
grundsätze haben und zu denen zählt auch
das im prinzip wir sicherstellen dass
jemand der schwere straftaten in
deutschland begeht hier nicht bleiben
kann es gibt umstände oder es dann dazu
führt dass es nicht möglich ist jemanden
dann abzuschieben und das ist jetzt
natürlich die situation dann schon alle
beteiligten alle verantwortlichen sagen
mittlerweile die große fehleinschätzung
dass das war eine vertrag das war ganz
fatal das hatte entsetzliche folgen
jetzt gibt es viele verantwortliche in
einer zentralen stelle mitverantwortlich
ist der spd-außenminister heiko maas
wollen sie denn eigentlich als
außenminister behalten jetzt geht es
darum die arbeit zu leisten die wir zu
leisten haben und das ist etwas was wir
alle mit großer intensität tun jeden tag
mit all den regierung zu sprechen auch
zu organisieren dass wir etwas erreichen
können für diejenigen die noch schutz
suchen jetzt in der konkreten situation
am flughafen von kabul in den
militärischen bereich aber wir versuchen
ja auch zu erreichen dass über diese
zeit hinaus die ausreise mögliches von
denjenigen denen wir solchen schutz
gewährleisten wollen und darüber reden
wir jetzt ganz intensiv auch in doha zum
beispiel das ist die aufgabe die jetzt
bewerkstelligt werden muss dann stellt
sich aber eben auch die frage der
verantwortung wir haben in dieser woche
von der bundeswehr zum beispiel gehört
dass bundeswehr veteran sein es muss
doch jemand verantwortung auch
übernehmen wenn sie jetzt nach vorne
schauen und sie wollen kanzler einer
kommende bundesregierung werden wäre
denn heiko maas dann wieder erste wahl
für das amt des außenministers
jetzt geht es um die arbeit hier zu
leisten müssen wie die nächste regierung
gebildet wird das entscheidet sich nach
der wahl ganz unabhängig von dieser
konkreten fall will ich gerne
ausdrücklich sagen ich finde es etwas
merkwürdig das jetzt irgendwie so im
wochentakt neue ministerien erfunden
werden und das auch sekunde wir sind
jetzt hier tatsächlich drei afghanistan
das gerät das auch ganz neues
ministerium sondern um die von anderen
würden sich auch einige schon für uns
neue ministerium bewerben das finde ich
sollte man lieber sein lassen das ist
nicht respektvoll vor den wählerinnen
und wählern den bürgern und bürgern die
am 26 september zu entscheiden haben und
deshalb macht es gar keinen sinn sich
jetzt über die zusammensetzung der
nächsten regierung auseinander zu setzen
da haben viele mit zu reden also über
die zukunft von heiko maas machen sie
sich jetzt noch keine gedanken sie haben
gerade eben beschrieben welche aufgaben
in afghanistan noch anstehen momentan
entscheiden die taliban darüber wen sie
noch rausholen können und wir nicht der
deutsche botschafter verhandelt dort
wird ihre bundesregierung eigentlich
eine taliban regierung die von den
taliban ja schon vorbereitet wird
anerkennen über die frage wie das da
demnächst weiter geht muss im geleitzug
mit all den anderen verbündeten
entschieden werden auch von der eu und
der nato müssen wir gemeinsam position
festlegen jetzt müssen wir erst mal
sicherstellen dass eine situation
entsteht wo wir was erreichen können zum
beispiel schon zum schutz derjenigen die
später noch ausreisen wollen und dann
die möglichkeit haben müssen dass auch
ungesichert zu tun das ist eine frage
die gerade intensiv versucht wird zu
erreichen der schutz der afghanen ist
ein gutes stichwort ihr konkurrent armin
laschet hat gerade viel kritik dafür
geerntet dass er sich öffentlich sorgen
gemacht hat über einen steigenden
migrationsdruck über flüchtende die aus
afghanistan versuchen heraus zu kommen
und vielleicht auch nach europa zu
kommen kann dann sehen sich die
bundesregierung tatsächlich
kann die bundesregierung in dieser frage
vorbeischauen
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass wir
immer überall auf der welt wo menschen
schutz zum beispiel nachbarländern
finden dazu beitragen müssen dass sie
dort eine perspektive finden das ist
mein die kritik am film was in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten weltweit
gemacht worden ist es gibt viele die
finden schutz in einem nachbarland in
afrika in asien im süden amerikas und da
können wir auch nicht immer sagen die
regierung sind so wie wir uns das
vorstellen soll müssen schutz möglich
machen und bin jetzt schutz stattfinden
kann in pakistan im iran im irak in der
türkei und in vielen anderen ländern die
an grenzen dann ist es wichtig dass wir
dort auch mit finanziellen mitteln über
internationale organisationen helfen und
das haben wir entschieden werden wir
auch tun dafür habe ich mich eingesetzt
die erste tranche ist schon bewilligt
damit der un hat er zum beispiel seine
aufgaben wahrnehmen kann zum schutz der
flüchtling die eu kommission fordert
mehr ursula von der leyen hat heute
gesagt die europäischen mitgliedsstaaten
sollten flüchtlinge direkt aufnehmen und
zwar im rahmen des umsiedlungsprogramm
der un des un flüchtlingshilfswerks wie
viele afghanen sollte deutschland im
rahmen dieser umsiedlung aufnehmen meine
these ist das ist erstmal darum gibt den
schutz vor ort möglich zu machen wir
sind gegenwärtig noch damit beschäftigt
sicherzustellen dass diejenigen die als
ortskräfte für uns tätig waren und
diejenigen die für andere organisationen
hilfsorganisationen tätig waren schutz
bekommen können dass wir sie nach
deutschland holen können das gilt
übrigens auch für männer und frauen die
jetzt politisch bedroht sind und
insbesondere die frauen die sich für die
gleichstellung eingesetzt haben denn das
finde ich dürfen wir doch nicht
vergessen hier ist jetzt eine große
katastrophe und viele sind unmittelbar
bedroht aber was jetzt ja auch
zerbrochen ist es der traum die hoffnung
vieler afghanen aufgaben auf ein anderes
besseres leben fernab von einer
islamistischen diktatur mit mehr
möglichkeiten für
kinder bildung zu bekommen mit besseren
möglichkeiten für mädchen und frauen
eine gute zukunft zu haben mit ein
bisschen rechtsstaat mit ein bisschen
demokratie und das ist das was glaube
ich der ganz traurigen moment ist dass
diese hoffnung natürlich jetzt alle
kaputt gehen und dass da vieles was
menschen sich für ein erstes leben
vorgestellt haben nicht funktionieren
wird ist ein außenpolitisches versagen
das sagen sehr viele ein kollege andreas
van dis ag vom netz hat das genannt den
außenpolitischen sargnagel der großen
koalition das ist ein hartes urteil aber
tatsächlich hat es ja in der großen
koalition auch schon vorher gerumpelt
die große koalition waren hier eine
liebesheirat sie war trotzdem ein
projekt für das sie sich in ihrer partei
sehr eingesetzt haben und andreas künast
zeigt uns einmal in 60 sekunden
wie diese geschichte machen
olaf scholz erfindet sich neu der mister
zukunft der spd stand über viele jahre
für deren vergangenheit für die
unbeliebte ja verhasste agenda 2010 für
die unbeliebte ja verhasste grob und hat
auch deshalb die wahl zum spd chef
verloren für seine kritiker war scholz
kein richtiger sozialdemokrat und wollte
auch keiner sein ein deutscher
finanzminister ist ein deutscher
finanzminister egal welches parteibuch
er hat als vizekanzler steht stolz wie
kein anderer sozialdemokrat für die
erfolge aber auch für die misserfolge
der aktuellen regierung die skandale
namens wirecard und namens comics haben
glaubwürdigkeit gekostet scholz stärke
ist die schwäche der anderen und eine
enorm disziplinierte partei über die
umfragewerte der spd redet scholz
inzwischen sehr gern nachdem er sie
früher sehr gern ignoriert hat aber olaf
scholz erfindet sich neu er schaut sich
neu erfinden das ist natürlich in einem
wahlkampf sehr verständlich das ist für
sie nicht ganz einfach weil sie sich aus
der großen koalition also aus der mitte
verantwortung heraus neu erfinden müssen
und ihre große koalition hatte in den
letzten jahren einige große krisen zu
bewältigen bei denen vor allem hängen
geblieben ist das ist viel
missmanagement gegeben hat sie haben die
große koalition lange als gemeinsames
projekt betrieben das heißt sie müssten
sie eigentlich auch für gemeinsame
fehler geradestehen und ich würde gerne
auf die korona krise konkret schauen als
beispiel nehmen wir da die
november/dezember hilfen die haben sie
gemeinsam mit herrn altmaier angekündigt
viel geld für unternehmer die in der
krise helfen sollten da waren sie sehr
stolz drauf und als es dann klar wurde
dass die auszahlung stockt das viele
noch im sommer danach das geld noch
nicht hatten da waren sie auf einmal
nicht mehr vorne mit dabei sondern
sagten das liegt vor allem an
wirtschaftsminister müssten sie da nicht
eigentlich gemeinsam für ein stehen für
solche fehler bin überzeugt dass wir das
richtige dieser krise gemacht haben
übrigens im wird das weltweit gelobt
deutschland krisenbekämpfung in
ökonomischer hinsicht wird als
goldstandard der wirtschaftlichen
krisenbekämpfung bezeichnet wir werden
am ende des nächsten jahres knapp 400
milliarden euro eingesetzt ganzes unter
dem namen in unternehmen zu retten um
dafür zu sorgen dass arbeitsplätze
erhalten werden wir haben über zwei
millionen arbeitsplätze mit der
kurzarbeit erhalten und die vielen
vielen milliarden zig milliarden weit
über 100 milliarden die man alle
zusammen rechnen kann die wir eingesetzt
haben damit aber immer geschützt werden
damit unternehmen durch die krise kommen
haben sich bezahlt gemacht so viel wie
wir in deutschland einsetzen hat niemand
in diesem ausmaß eingesetzt ich habe
immer wieder mit europäischen
kommissarinnen und kommissaren
gesprochen die gesagt haben er scheut
sie sind nur ein kleiner teil der
europäischen bevölkerung aber wenn man
alles genau betrachtet setzt deutschland
zur rettung seiner arbeitsplätze und
seiner unternehmen fast die hälfte der
gesamtsumme in europa ein das geld zur
verfügung zu stellen dass das eine ist
muss aber auch ankommen und sie haben
vielfach kritisiert dass es so langsam
geht da waren sie mit der kritik dabei
aber nicht mit der mitverantwortung
warum übernehmen sie da nicht zusammen
mit 1 altmaier die verantwortung wenn es
nicht glauben dass ihre analyse falsch
ist auch wenn sie das zugespitzt hier
betrachten und die bürgerinnen und
bürger das auch nicht so sehen wir frage
den eindruck erweckt die wissen schon
dass wir das richtige gemacht haben und
das ist richtig war so viele mittel in
die hand zu nehmen damit wir jetzt auch
wieder einen aufschwung sehen können
denn das ist ja das was niemand vor
einiger zeit wirklich erwartet hat dass
wir nach einer so schweren weltweiten
krise jetzt schon wieder den anfang
eines aufschwungs sehen und im nächsten
jahr gute wachstumsraten erwarten können
wir sind durch diese krise viel besser
gekommen als fast alle prognostiziert
haben und das ist gut es gab viel kritik
für die impfstoff beschaffung auch da
waren sie persönlich nicht zufrieden
wollten druck machen und haben bei uns
in berlin direkt nachdem sie einen
beauftragten impfstoff beauftragten
eingesetzt haben folgendes gesagt es
wird bis zu zehn millionen impfungen pro
woche geben und dass das jetzt gut
vorbereitet wird dafür habe ich gesorgt
dafür haben sie gesorgt zehn millionen
impfungen im monat haben sie gesagt
tatsächlich waren es dann im juni gerade
mal 55 millionen impfungen das ist
gerade mal die hälfte dessen was sie
versprochen haben tragen sie dafür
persönlich die verantwortung
ich bin sehr froh dass wir diese
ausweitung möglich gemacht haben dass es
wirklich erreicht worden und es war
wichtig dass wir am anfang des jahres
einmal diskutiert haben dass man im
vorletzten jahr hätte mehr impfstoff
bestellen können seitens der
eu-kommission damit das mal klar
ausgesprochen ist und da nicht rüber
herum gerätselt wird aber ansonsten
mussten wir uns ja darum kümmern dass
die impfstoffproduktion ausgeweitet wird
dass wir alles tun dafür dass er schnell
zu den bürgern und bürgern kommt und in
der situation in der wir miteinander
diskutiert haben weil es für mich auch
wichtig zu sagen wir diskutieren noch
über den mangel an impfstoff wir werden
sehr schnell in die situation kommen
dass sehr viel zur verfügung steht
bereitet euch alle darauf vor dass der
auch verimpft werden kann mittlerweile
haben wir eine situation in der
impfstoff genügend zur verfügung steht
und wir aktuell alle bürgern und bürger
auffordern müssen dass sie wenn sie es
noch nicht gemacht haben sich jetzt
impfen lassen viele millionen
bürgerinnen 50 millionen bürgern bürger
sind mittlerweile umfassend geschützt
ungefähr und das ist für mich ein
hinweis an diejenigen die noch zweifelt
zusagen macht das doch bei den anderen
ist es auch gut gegangen bei ihm bei mir
wie vielen und ich glaube das ist jetzt
der appell der in dieser minute richtig
und notwendig ist die korona krise hat
sich natürlich nicht angekündigt ist
allerdings eine große krise gewesen mit
einer anderen krise die man hätte
absehen können haben sie sich auch
auseinandersetzen muss nun haben viel
kritik dafür bekommen dass die
bundesregierung das nicht schneller und
entschiedener gehandelt hat ich rede von
der klimakrise da haben sie das
klimapaket er ist unter massiven
gesellschaftlichen druck gespürt dann
ist es auch noch teilweise vom
bundesverfassungsgericht kassiert worden
wenn sie immer sagen sie packen das
anders ihnen am herzen liegt warum lag
eben das damals nicht am herzen wir
haben in deutschland ein gesetz werde
den ausbau erneuerbarer energien das ist
ohne sozialdemokratische politik in den
letzten jahren nicht nur der letzten
vier jahre gar nicht möglich gewesen so
etwas zustand wäre es nicht möglich
gewesen so etwas zustande zu kriegen
viele sagen dass reichten wir haben den
nacht und wir haben den ausstieg aus der
atomenergie beschlossen das wird jetzt
in kürze vollzogen
haben den ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung geschlossen und wir
haben entschieden dass wir ein
klimaschutzgesetz durchsetzen das ist
auch den sozialdemokraten in der
regierung gelungen das festlegt dass wir
bis 2045 co2 neutral wirtschaften wollen
das ist ein riesiges projekt 250 jahre
haben wir unseren wirtschaftlichen
wohlstand in der industrie gegründet auf
der nutzung von kohle von gas und öl und
wenn wir jetzt in knapp 25 jahren das
ändern wollen dann ist das die größte
wirtschaftliche und industrielle
modernisierung deutschlands zeit lang
das sind wahrscheinlich der
grundschulklassen erinnerung haben dann
müssen sie schneller werden das sagen
sie selber jetzt im wahlkampf auch immer
wieder sie kündigen einen neustart in
der klimapolitik an haben aber im
wahlkampf gerade erst bei kohle
arbeitern den eindruck gemacht dass ihre
arbeitsplätze auf jeden fall bis 2038
sicher sind da hat frau esken auf
twitter sich berufen gefühlt das
öffentlich zu kritisieren bzw zu
korrigieren und zu sagen nein es kann
auch früher sein was gilt denn jetzt man
muss ja nicht jede pressemitteilung die
politische wettbewerber verschicken als
realistische frage stellen also deshalb
mal ganz klar deutschland hat einen
vertrag geschlossen da geht endet das
mit der kohleverstromung spätestens 238
später und die frage ist kann auch und
die frage wann wir fertig werden hat
nichts damit zu tun ob man über diesen
punkt diskutiert sondern ob wir es
schaffen dass wir jetzt den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien hinbekommen und
wenn sie es nicht hinbekommen kann es
vorher sein das ist die frage und dann
bitte drücken sie sich auch nicht vor
der wichtigsten herausforderung von der
deutschland steht das möchte ich ihnen
auch ganz konkret sagen und vielen
anderen wir müssen ist nämlich
hinbekommen dass wir schon im nächsten
jahr der regierung beschliessen dass die
ausbauziele für die stromproduktion nach
oben gesetzt werden der
wirtschaftsminister und die union haben
bis vor kurzem behauptet da gibt es
keinen bedarf für mehr aber jetzt haben
sie bekundet 100 terawattstunden mehr
230 für die chemieindustrie wissen wir
dass wir am ende dieses zeitraums so
viel strom brauchen damit co2 neutral
gewirtschaftet werden kann und eine gute
industrielle zukunft für unser land gibt
mit guten arbeitsplätzen
wenn das die dafür so viel strom
brauchen wir deutschland heute insgesamt
das muss im ersten jahr der neuen
regierung festgelegt werden und alle
gesetze so geändert werden dass wir auch
fertig werden heute dauert ihre die
genehmigung einer windkraftanlage sechs
jahre das können sechs monate werden das
ist die aufstellung von der bestehen ob
das dann mit einem früheren
kohleausstieg kommt oder nicht das
müssen wir dann sehen unsere zeit ist
hier leider schon vorbei herr scholz ich
danke ihnen für das genau
das war das letzte zdf-sommerinterview
für dieses jahr in der kommenden woche
begrüßt sie an dieser stelle wieder theo
koll mit berlin direkt herzlichen dank
fürs zuschauen und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]